hey youtubers is Charlie bunch of DC
stuff happening this week so this is
gonna be a video all about the
differences between the flash TV show
like flash season 3 in the flash movie
now those won't necessarily happen at
the same time by the time we get to the
flash movie will be on like season 5 but
this is just for comparison so I will be
talking about stuff that happens during
the flash season 2 so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen season 2
yet but there are a couple really big
visual differences just in the pitch
right away right now the flash movie is
supposed to be a team-up with cyborg so
that doesn't mean like Batman V Superman
was a team-up because that wasn't really
a team-up movie of even though Batman
and Superman were in it it just means
that the central plot will revolve
around both characters instead of it
being about one character and then
another one coming in much later in the
film so I think we can guess that STAR
Labs is going to be deeply involved with
what's going on with cyborgs technology
because we got all those Justice League
teasers during Batman V Superman
we saw cyborg getting integrated with
the mother box getting his technology so
because Justice League is happening
before the flash movie I'm expecting a
Civil War spider-man type situation
where everyone's like here's this
character he's already the cyborg so
it's not gonna be an origin story during
Justice League but over the course of
that movie and then the flash movie
where he becomes a much more central
character they'll deal with his
backstory in flashbacks and really
interesting ways so I really like the
idea Marvel is kind of doing the same
thing with people's backstories where a
movie isn't a complete origin story in
the linear way that they used to do them
in big Hollywood movies they try to
start you off with some big oh
moment and then when things slow down
when they need to breathe they address
backstory they get really psychological
with stuff like that so by the time you
get to the flash movie and you see
cyborg and flash working together you'll
already know a lot about both of those
characters and I mean obviously some
characters you probably know about going
into the theater more than others so
have you been watching the flash TV show
you already know all about Barry's
origin story how he got his powers who
some of his biggest villains are so the
flash movie isn't gonna retread a lot of
those things thankfully I'm so happy
about that even if the flash movie in
the flash TV show are gonna be
completely separate they're not going to
be stepping on each other's toes so what
about Barry Allen and the movies though
how is he going to be different from
Barry Allen and the tea
oh that's really probably the big
question Ezra Miller is supposed to be
the flash as of now nothing's changed
about that so far they did change to a
new director which I actually I think
it's a good move I didn't know much
about the last director I know a little
bit more about the new guy they brought
in and he's someone who does a really
good job tackling hard core subjects
without losing any of the fun character
moments and that's really important for
the flash movie I mean it's important
for all movies that they stay fun even
though they get really serious but the
flash as a character is much closer to
Superman then say the tone of a Batman
film so the flash movie is scheduled for
release in March of 2018 that will be
during the back half of the flash season
5 so it's really hard to imagine what
the flash TV show is gonna be doing by
then because they're doing flashpoint
right now they're already doing such
crazy storylines from the comics which I
really like I'll address that in a
second but if there's anything that you
ever wanted to see on the flash TV show
they will have done it pretty much every
major concept from the comics every
giant character big storyline so by the
time we get to season 5 they'll be
mixing and matching a lot of things
doing super weird things the flash movie
will stay a little more grounded in that
it's gonna be beholden to what the big
arc is of all the Justice League films
and that's mostly New Gods darkside war
but one of the big differences about the
flash is that he can time travel I'm not
expecting them to do a flashpoint arc in
the movies but I do think that we'll see
say like the reverse flash the biggest
fail on eobard thawne will probably see
more New Gods and they'll probably dive
deeper into things that they teased
during Justice League one of these
things these big Justice League movies
do is they tease bits for the other like
the spin-off movies to pick up on and
run with so I'm expecting to see a
couple flash related characters get some
name drops for certain things that
they'll just pick up and run with in the
other movies and a lot of that will just
depend on what ends up happening during
Justice League it'll be a big film but
they're saying it will be easier to
follow than Batman V Superman which just
kind of had too much stuff's thrown into
it all at the same time but one of the
big advantages of the flash is that it's
one of those comics that had been
running for a long time it's been
popular for a long time so there are so
many more flash stories than there are
say for some of the other characters
like cyborg for instance which is why I
think they're pairing psy
or quit the flash just because there's
so much more flash cannon for them to
dig through and that is not true of
cyborg cyborg is a relatively simple
character pretty simple concept so if
you remember the flash season 2 with the
way it addressed the speedforce wormhole
aliens that's not necessarily something
that's spelled out in the comics
specifically that way this B force isn't
really given an intelligence in that way
but it's one of those TV shows that's
starting to bounce back and forth
between spiritual type of stories and
really science based techies stories
very much like Deep Space 9 which is
really awesome because that was my
favorite Star Trek series and they dealt
with your more traditional Star Trek
sci-fi fare but also managed to get into
spirituality God's religion faiths
things like that so the TV show will be
all over that stuff the way Ezra Miller
was talking about the flash movie made
it sound like it's going to be more in
the world of science so think more
tachyon device velocity 9 then say like
Speed Force wormhole aliens that the TV
show is doing so one of the other big
differences between the movie and the TV
show is there'll be a lot more CG though
they'll have a much larger budget for
special effects so I'm expecting them to
do the Spider Man Civil War thing where
a lot of the flash suit is CG there's
like a mixture of practical effects and
CG like Tom Holland for instance in
Civil War all those badass Airport
battle spider-man scenes you saw 100% CG
that part of the movie specifically was
made in a computer so they might go the
same route with the flash costume as
opposed to grant gustin's costume which
is 100% practical with like a little bit
of CG added for lightning if they need
it but that's really true of any movie
and TV show TV shows tend to do less
special effects but cyborg is another
good example of someone who's going to
have heavy CG because if you remember
that quick scene of him during Batman V
Superman he barely looked human I mean
like Robocop levels of cyborg but it's a
good example when you're talking about
cyborgs where it's like you know you
have a head you have part of a brain but
really like aside from like lungs and
maybe a spine that's about it the rest
of him is completely machine but even
though the flash movie is really far
away let me know in the comments what
kind of story do you want them to do I
think it's gonna be a lot like Ben
Affleck's Batman movie he's been talking
a lot about that about how he'll be
pulling a lot from the
comics but it will still be something of
an original story in the way that Batman
V Superman was an original story even
though they did a lot of Frank Miller
Dark Knight Returns Batman visually it
was inspired by that even though the
story itself was something original
so we'll probably see a lot of people
associated with STAR Labs but I'm not
expecting any of the TV actors to make
it into the movie I'm definitely
expecting them to stick with Ezra Miller
they're filming justice league right now
Ezra Miller is the flash in that so it's
not like they're gonna change from one
flash to the other between Justice
League movies so he has a huge bummer
that Grant Gustin can't be the flash of
the movies but just remember the flash
movie won't be more than like two and a
half hours tops
even that is probably little too long
it'll probably be a little bit shorter
than that meaning they're not gonna have
time to do half of the stories that they
do on the flash TV show so if you want
to see a really awesome comic book arc
play out on screen you want to meet all
these supporting characters like killer
frost Caitlin snow see all these other
worlds in the multiverse that's what the
TV show is for the flash movie is more
about telling this Justice League story
weaves in and out of all these Justice
League spin-off films so when people ask
me do you think that when they do the
flash movie they're gonna have to stop
doing the flash TV show I just I laughed
so hard that is never ever gonna be an
issue it's like I just did a Justice
League video earlier today I try to
clarify a little bit about what Geoff
Johns does he's mostly there to correct
the tone of the film's to make sure that
nothing goes way off base but he's also
a person who advises the TV shows on
stuff that it's totally cool to do so I
think now that they've gotten rid of
some of the more toxic elements to
storytelling in the movie universe I
think the movies will be able to step
around the TV shows a little bit easier
without having to all over stuff
that the TV shows are trying to do so do
not worry about the Flash movie
affecting the stuff that they do on the
flash TV show and who knows maybe
they'll be like a small cameo just for
fun like an uncredited cameo that's what
I'm hoping for in terms of TV actors
being in the movies but here's a big
question for you guys
if Grant Gustin could have a cameo in
the flash movie just for fun what would
you want the cameo to be I think it'd be
really funny if he worked as like a
barista or if he worked at a donut shop
or if he had an ice-cream truck
it'd just be a nice way to do a cameo in
the DC movie so be an Easter Egg for
that
but it also be an easter egg for story
things that they've done on the TV shows
but beats up happening this weekend
bunch of Game of Thrones dropping
tomorrow so be sure to subscribe to get
all that stuff and congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner austin
cornell you win a $20 Amazon gift card
be sure to private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details that's just on the about
page so while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
learn all about what's going on with the
Justice League movie Geoff Johns just
explained a whole bunch of stuff and you
can click here for all my Ninja Turtles
Easter eggs thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight